In the subarctic Lapland region in circles
seen from space.
Sami herdsmen are at the centre of a
stampede called a reindeer cyclone.
But something's wrong.
The semi normally lit reindeer roam free.
There are hundreds of reindeer in these huge
circular pens.
What on earth is going on here?
Could this be an culling?
But the Sammy approached not with knives or
guns, but something else.
I've seen this kind of equipment before.
These guys are probing for radiation.
Sensors on the abdomen.
Test the tissue for radioactivity.
But why?
This is an utterly remote corner of
subarctic wilderness.
I'm looking at this area and there is no
nuclear plant.
There's no nuclear testing facility.
Why are they testing these reindeer for
radioactivity?
According to the Sami tribesmen here, the
problems began more than 30 years ago.
In fact, they know the exact date in 1986.
This is the year of Chernobyl.
In communist Russia.
On April 26th, poorly trained engineers
begin safety tests at the badly designed
nuclear plant outside the city of Chernobyl.
A drop in power causes a chain reaction and
reactor four explodes.
Firing a deadly cloud of cesium 137 into the
atmosphere.
Radiation equivalent to 400 nuclear bombs.
Chernobyl is the single worst disaster in the
history of atomic power.
It's the world's first ever level seven
nuclear incident.
But how does a disaster at a Soviet nuclear
power plant have any bearing on radioactive
reindeer? More than a thousand miles away in
Sweden.
Weather satellites point to the answer.
Up in the latitudes of parts of Europe.
The winds are actually flowing from east to
west.
Following the explosion.
The radioactive cloud above the decimated
power station begins drifting westwards.
Over Ukraine.
And on to Sweden.
The Soviet government.
Is covering up the entire incident.
This toxic cloud of cesium 137 is
propagating across Europe, and most people
have no idea.
November 10th, 2016, a satellite flying above
Maryland spots something strange.
First thing that pops out is this giant white
bubble here in the middle of the landscape.
It looks like a radome, a golf ball type
structure that protects super powerful radar
systems. But at 200ft across, it is far too
big and the wrong shape.
It literally looks like a giant egg.
It almost looks like a spaceship has landed.
It even looks like there's a stairway
leading up into it.
What makes the Dome especially intriguing is
its location.
Aberdeen Proving Ground, part of Edgewood
Arsenal.
The scene of secret experiments carried out
on humans living and dead.
You really have to.
Wonder what kind of tests would require a
facility like we see in the image.
Possible evidence comes from an FBI raid on
an Arizona warehouse in January 2014.
Inside, agents discover buckets of limbs and
a female head sewn onto another body destined
for sale to the US military.
The FBI files on this investigation have been
sealed, so there's no real way to know which
bodies ended up at which military bases and
what kind of tests they were subjected to.
Human experimentation at the base and the
image began decades ago.
A lot of work is classified, but some
programs like Operation Delirium, where US
soldiers were dosed with PCP, sarin gas,
just to test the effects.
Those types of drills were conducted at this
location.
The authorities claim that experiments on
humans have now ceased.
April 12th, 2019.
An Earth observation satellite passing over
the Western Sahara captures this image of the
Richat structure.
The Richard structure is the most
extraordinary spiral like arrangement of
rocks with these brown and blue lines.
I mean, it looks spectacular and it's hardly
surprising.
People have called it the Eye of the Sahara.
Since it was first photographed by Gemini,
four astronauts in 1965.
The precise origin of the 25 mile diameter
structure has baffled investigators.
Yet the 2019 image reveals another mystery
hidden within its concentric circles.
In the middle of the picture is an almost
perfect square with loops on the corners.
The presence of the unusual loan structure
baffles archaeologists.
What's really strange is that it's it's there
in the middle of absolutely nowhere.
This isn't a place.
It's pretty inhospitable to life.
There's no arable land.
You're quite a long way from anything that
could be considered civilization.
How can you possibly survive out here?
Why would you need a structure like this?
According to one legend, the structure is
somehow aligned to the greatest mythical city
of antiquity.
One of the most intriguing theories about the
eye of the Sahara is that it's actually the
lost city of Atlantis.
In the fourth century BC, the philosopher
Plato writes about the lost civilization
beneath the waves.
Plato's description of Atlantis begins with
an island in the middle, and it's surrounded
by concentric rings of land.
I can see how looking at the eye of the
Sahara could resemble his description of
Atlantis.
Looking at the image, it's immediately
apparent that this is the Saqqara Mortuary
complex of the stepped pyramid of Djoser.
The pyramid is 4700 years old, making it the
oldest pyramid in the world.
But to a trained eye, there's something in
the image that doesn't look right.
You can clearly see from above something that
I think would not be visible at all from the
ground.
Looking at the image, there is a faint
outline of something underneath the sand.
Further analysis of the image compounds the
mystery.
If you look closely at this image, you can
see that this is actually around the entire
pyramid and not just on the west side.
The satellite appears to have revealed a
series of massive hidden structures
surrounding one of the wonders of the
ancient world.
This image is absolutely incredible how
intricate this whole system is.
What are those things for?
When teams of archaeologists begin
excavating, what they discover shocks them.
It's extraordinary.
What these teams are finding is that this is
actually a trench.
It's a continuous rectangular enclosure, for
want of a better word.
Analysis suggests the giant trench stretches
nearly 2500ft by 2000ft.
This raises a whole host of questions.
What is this trench?
Why was it dug?
And does it relate somehow to the ceremonial
function of this site?
September 8th, 2018.
The Worldview three satellite over San
Francisco Bay, California spot some strange
activity.
This ship has.
What seems like a really long tail just
dragging behind the ship.
I mean, what could it be for?
It's really weird to see a ship pulling
something so long and skinny.
Scale analysis reveals the mystery tale is
2000ft long.
You see these tiny little white bulbs along
the line and I'm wondering if they're buoys
for a net, specifically a gill net.
If this is a giant drift gillnet, its
presence here alarms experts.
Maritime law prohibits this kind of fishing
within three miles of the coast and with good
reason.
Gillnets are this microfilament curtain that
hangs down from this big line of boys that
are floating across the surface of the
water.
If a fish tries to swim through it, which
they try to often, they're caught head deep
in by their gills.
And their gills get stuck so they can no
longer respirate and they actually drown in
the water.
It's like a giant wall of death.
Once deployed, Gillnets can be left
unattended.
Because these nets are left alone out there
in the ocean.
They sometimes get lost.
They can break away from their anchors.
A big storm can come through.
And now you have a giant floating gill net
just cruising on its own.
Every year, a fishery operating in the
Atlantic loses 25,000 of them.
June 26th, 2015.
In orbit over Kansas.
In the Midwest of the United States, the
Landsat Copernicus satellite captures this
image.
This satellite image is intriguing.
It shows a number of symbols, crosses,
lines, X's triangles, seemingly in a
random pattern carved into the landscape.
Some of the shapes almost look like letters
A, Z.
A T. Is there a code here?
Of course. The immediate question is what do
they mean?
When archaeologist Karen Bellinger studies
the image, she sees something familiar in the
patterns.
There are sites around the world where
symbols similar to some of the things I'm
seeing in this image have been found in
ancient, ancient rock art, in caves and in
petroglyphs.
Bellinger reveals that nine of the shapes
match a series of 32 symbols engineered by
our far distant ancestors.
They are found in sites throughout the world,
everywhere humans have settled and sites that
are very old, I mean, 40,000 years old and
more.
They are purposeful and they are repeated
time and again.
What baffles analysts is that the same
symbols appeared around the world before
international trade and travel became
widespread.
The fact that.
Only 32 symbols emerge as consistent, utterly
consistent across time and space leads some
to theorize that this is some early form of
communication.
If these symbols found around the world are
an early form of language, they predate the
earliest known written texts.
Sumerian cuneiform by over 30,000 years.
If this were to be proven, it would be earth
shattering.
It would rewrite our timeline for the
development of human intellect and artistic
creativity.
Studies suggest that humans arrive in North
America at least 20,000 years ago.
Yet ancient peoples have tended to leave
symbolic markings on rock faces or as
geoglyphs not carved deep into the land like
this.